welcome to this video playing Herman
Steiner from the US and his plane
quickly as this much is apparent / great
camp at CI a-- hmm i wanted to study
this it's a good what really okay yeah I
don't know cuz I I don't know I wanted
to look at night before but Bishop d3 is
really a weird response then that looks
utterly strange to me at least giving
black to bishops in an open position for
him and he does not even have a big
development edge but ok ok why probably
is still slick William nothing nothing
terrible happening time yeah two bishops
but I don't have don't have much space
this is the problem
yeah was c5 a c5 movement I can play b6
bit lame still probably probably
reasonable and then I came he is totally
fine with this with this advantage in
space and takes
we came out too much knight Knight to c6
this really really a problem sometimes
trying to keep a little bit of tension i
can take Queen d2 rookie one just
straight trade everything ok it's not
doing that ok so maybe I can provoke
some sort of weakness but it's really
not yeah it's really nothing going on
here this is the real problem i want to
i would like to do something here I'm
very close to this 2,500 mark but the
position does not really allow for
anything check it's really just just
nothing going on if anybody he's maybe a
little bit better Bishop d7 should fire
I can go back him
night c7.r is a threat and here on a
seven I don't like to take definitely
not
mom this means i have i have misplayed
that yeah i have to take it's not
nothing nothing to do about it Queen you
ate maybe it's still a draw but yeah
she's six yeah I can Queenie a 27-21
Crete XF to Queen have to check and see
eight at the end not sure g6 yeah well
okay g6 he can give this check but
Bishop g7 s is okay check of course I
don't mind the mind to trade those
bishops the bishop in relation to the
pawn structure this is my problem a
bishop end game might be fatal long-term
Bishop g5 Queenie aidid's to it it
should draw up I can put the King to d7
and just shuffle I mean I cannot do
anything active ever but it shouldn't
shouldn't be a big danger if he takes it
Queenie 7 is there something probably
probably not so much
Oh
wow that's nice
the cross pin very nice Jim I'm lost
funny if it's not not exactly out of
nowhere but it's still surprising
Joe Black resigns ah and this is the end
of this winning run against this is this
kind of this kind of stuff yeah mmm-hmm
yeah of course this Queen to a 6 was was
a stupid idea around here is really
equal I mean if I just want to want to
state okay i'm equally i can just hack
this night which is maybe the easiest I
mean I cannot really win hear them but
you don't want really want that and
let's want to try okay this is this is
this is a bit a bit bit if he know but
ok it's a matter of I need to play some
precise moves and I'm okay if I don't
run into this this tactic I really don't
have a problem even this is probably
playable let's probably play or you can
give this check but there's nothing
happening yeah nice tactic that you saw
that the edge okay well thanks for
watching